الطبوبي قال لينا الاتحاد العام لشغل قدم
رؤيته بشان خطه الاصلاح الحكوميه لكنه لم
يجد اذانا صاغيه واضاف ان كلمه الحوار
اصبحت بمثابه جريمه في تونس كما ندد
بتصريحات الرئيس قيس سعيد الاخيره بشان
المهاجرين الافارقه واعلن ترحيبه بهم في
البلاد
كلمه الحوار كان الجريمه ونحن في على ارض
التسامح ارض الانفتاح معناها على الحضارات
ارض يقلب بالرعي والراي المخالف ارض
لنلتقي الى قاعده الاختلاف الراي ارض
لنلتقي فيها ننبض العمق ولكن قوه الحجه
والاقناع
واقولها كذلك
لابنائنا واخوتنا من المهاجرين الافارقه
تونس بلد التسامح بلد الالتقاء لا للميز
العنصري نحن نداف على الحقوق الكونيه
للانسان يدافع على انسانيه الانسان
من تونس الله ملينا مراسل الجزيره سيف
الدين ابو علان ابقى معك في اجواء
المظاهره الاحتجاجيه اليوم المطالب
وشعارات وكلام الطبوب كذلك
اهم
ما كان ربما السماء البارزه لكلمه نوردين
التبوبي الامين العام للاتحاد العام
التونسي الشغل اليوم هو الوضوح وتوجيه
الرسائل بشكل مباشر الى الرئيس قيس سعيد
وهو راس باعتباره راس السلطه التنفيديه
والذي يمتلك اكبر صلاحيات حسب النظام
السياسي والدستوري الجديد تحدث حول جمله
من المسائل ابرزها يتعلق بالحريات العامه
بشكل كعام والحريات النخابيه بشكل خاص
ويتحدث عن وجود السلسله من انتهاكات التي
طالت عدد من النشطاء والسياسيين
والنقابيين
والاعلاميين والنشطاء في المجتمع المدني
وتحدث ايضا عن السلسله الايقافات التي
طالت السياسيين ونشطاء ونقابيين وبالتالي
قال انه لا مكانه للقمع في او لاي
السلوكيات او انحرافات بالتجربه في تونس
بعد الثوره ولا يمكن لاي شخص ان يستبد
بالسلطه في تونس سواء قبل قبل الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو او بعد الخامس والعشرين
من يوليو ويقول ايضا ان الحريات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه باتت ايضا مهدده
مثلها مثل الحريات العامه وحريه الراي
والتعبير والتنظم طبعا هو يتحدث عن سلسله
الايقافات الاخيره من بينها كان هناك
نقابيون في الجامعه العامه للنقل ونقابي
اخر وقيادي نقابي في جامعه او في شركه
السكك او عفوا شركه الطرقات السياره وايضا
تحدث عن الازمه التي خلفتها تصريحات
الرئيس قيس سعيد حول الافارقه جنوب
الصحراء وسلسله الانتهاكات التي وثقتها
منظمات مثل الرابطه التونسيه للدفاع التي
طالت عددا من المهاجرين وقال دانا طبعا
الامين العام نور الدين بهذه الممارسات
وايضا تحدث عن ان تونس دوله
للحريات ودوله للانسانيه ولا يمكن ان يتم
استهداف اي مقيم في تونس وتحدث ايضا عن
مساله اخرى مهمه هي مساله ترحيل احد
النخبيين الاسباني ومنع مقابيل الجانب
اخرين المشاركه والتضامن مع الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل وايضا طرد واعتبارها شخصيه
غير مرغوبه وهي استر ليش رئيسه
الكونفدراليه النقابات الاوروبيه جميع هذه
المواقف تحدث عنها الامين العام للاتحاد
العام التونسي الشغل بشكل مباشر ثم تطرق
الى المساله الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه خاصه
المفاوضات مع صندوق النقد الدولي التي
يتكتم كما يقول الاتحاد العام للشغل تتكتم
السلطات حول فحوى هذه الاتفاقات حول
الاصلاحيه الاصلاحات التي تعتزم السلطات
التنفيذها الاتحاد يريد اولا وضوح على
الرؤيه للحكومه وايضا يريد هناك نقاط
حمراء تتعلق برفع الدعم عن المواد
الاساسيه يرفضها الاتحاد يرفض تجميد
الاجور ويرفض وقف الانتدابات في القطاع
العام نعم شكرا جزيلا
من تونس